well joining us right now republican
senator john kennedy uh
senator we gave you a lot of information
there's still a lot we don't know but
one thing is predictable
the gun debate is back
well brian look these killings were were
terrible
they were they were horrible i'm
reminded though that uh
you know america is a big country we're
free
and one of the prices we pay for that
freedom is that
you're always going to have some people
who abuse it
freedom is risk what we've got to
concentrate on is how to
control that risk you're not going to
stop the killings until you stop the
killers
but you you don't stop drunk drivers by
getting rid of all
sober drivers which is what many of my
democratic friends want to do with
respect to the second amendment
and my judgment we do not need more gun
control
we need more idiot control how do we do
that
we've already tried the republicans have
senator grass grassley senator cruz
had a bill to to strengthen our national
database
we regulate gun ownership in america if
you uh
if you're convicted of certain crimes if
you have a tendency to violence if
you're
if you're mentally ill and you want to
buy a gun your name has to
run through a database the problem is
the database has huge holes in it
and many federal agencies and state
agencies are very cavalier about sending
in the names
grassley and cruz's bill which i support
would have would have tightened up the
database
and it would have cracked down on people
who have guns who shouldn't have guns
you know why the bill didn't pass many
of my democratic
colleagues filibustered it now
if you drill down far enough what you're
going to find i don't want to paint but
with too broad brush
but but many not all many of my
democratic colleagues they just don't
believe in the second amendment
they just don't right i mean we've heard
it
in terms of police officers
i mean basically the democratic position
is that if a
if a bad guy shoots a cop it's the gun's
problem
if a cop shoots a bad guy it's the cops
fault
you know if it weren't for double
standards here we wouldn't have any
standards at all here's what the
president said today
calling on he wants this to happen right
away in the house and the senate listen
the united states senate i hope some are
listening should immediately pass
the two house pass bills that close
loopholes in the background check system
we should also ban assault weapons in
the process it looks like this guy
bought his gun six days ago
is there anything about that these two
gun control
measures that are now the senate's
looking at that would address
anything to do with what happened here
today as we know it yes
and if president biden or whoever's
making the decisions at the white house
really wants to do something about this
problem they will support
senator grassley's and senator cruz's
bill
well let me say it again we all ready
regulate guns in america
right you the database has holes in it
big enough to drive a mack truck through
why wasn't th the killer in boulder's
name in the database let's find out
let's plug the holes and enforce the law
molly hemingway said something pretty
intriguing at the end of brett bear show
saying we might find out that the fbi
was tracking him
so we do have a lot of questions that
need to be answered i want to put up a
couple of full screens
there's some staggering numbers of gun
violence in inner city where the
gun controls are very very strict
especially the one
i'm in take a look at some of these
numbers in terms of shooting
they're pretty stark i mean in chicago
112 homicides so far this year 506
shooting incidents so far this year in
los angeles
77 homicides since uh up until march
13th
303 shootings as well in new york city
68 homicides 227
shooting victims people are upset about
law enforcement there
guns good gun controls have never been
stricter here we got a huge problem in
our inner cities
where's the outrage then well look i
don't want to again paint with too broad
brush brian
but this is not just about databases and
and and checks for guns and that sort of
thing this is about the second amendment
many of my democratic colleagues just
don't support it
you know when when a when a when a
g-artist who happens to be a muslim
blows up a school full of school
children and kills them all we're told
don't judge all muslims because of the
acts of a few
and i agree with that how come the same
rule doesn't apply to the 100 million
gun owners
in america could never abuse their right
so i want you to see what's uh with
former president obama rang in with
today who's evidently in constant
contact with the current president
united states i wonder if this is
president obama's third term
but among the things that he has said
and i'll i'll read it and it's kind of
calling you out
at the end of this he says it will take
time to root out the disaffection racism
misogyny that fuels so many of these
senseless acts
of violence okay but we can make it
harder for those with hate in their
hearts to buy weapons of war and he goes
on
we can overcome opposition by cowardly
politicians
and the pressure of a gun lobby that
opposes any limit on the ability for
anyone to assemble
an arsenal we can and we must are you a
cowardly politician well the president
is a former president it's entitled his
opinion this is america
i'm just telling him that we already and
to me this is a natural
fact we already regulate guns in america
we have the laws we're just not
enforcing them we need to enforce them
if you pass the grassley and cruz bill
and he would tell his democratic friends
not to filibuster it to death
then we could do something about this
problem senator kenny as we speak right
now
our board has been our border is being
simply invaded uh by what looks like
three predominant central american
uh countries even some uh ot uh from
mexicans are coming through our border
at dizzying rate
we couldn't get some pictures inside the
facility but finally uh it looks like
after
the embarrassment of the weekend of
their homeland security secretary just
pretending as if
they're worried about the the
journalists getting or giving
uh the coronavirus to would-be illegal
immigrants they provided some footage of
what's going on
in these soft cell these soft
uh facilities where a lot of these under
uh underage minors are unaccompanied
minors are
what is your take about what you're
seeing and along with the axios pictures
given to us by
congressman henry cuellar well for the
last four years
i've listened to many of my democratic
friends and mr biden he wasn't president
then
call all of us who believed in a secure
border a bunch of races
but we pressed on anyway and when
president biden became president biden
he inherited the most secure border in
my lifetime as a result of the actions
of a republican congress
i hate to tell you they don't believe
that they said trump left him a mess
well they're wrong you know one of us is
right and the other
is wrong and the other one is them uh
they inherited the most secure border in
my lifetime
so what did president biden do on his
very first day he got rid of all the
policy and practices
that we implemented to secure the border
now one need not be
be clairvoyant to see what was going to
happen uh people flooded in
yep now the people making these
decisions in the white house either one
or two things are true
either they're like a rock only dumber
and never saw this coming and i don't
believe that
or they knew it was going to happen and
they're okay with it
what they're upset about what they're
really upset about
is they thought they would get a free
pass from many members of the democratic
media
and they haven't they haven't they've
been caught absolutely
and they believe in open borders and no
offense
i don't want them shooting my footage we
can do it ourselves
i'd rather them not edit our footage
either we could do that ourselves
it would be a lot more intellectually
honest if president biden and his people
would just come out and say hey
america we believe in open borders get
used to it senator kennedy i'd like to
have you for the whole hour but i
couldn't afford your fee so i'm going to
have to let you go now i can only pay
you for 11 minutes
thanks so much senator have a great
night